hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast extracellular vesicle
isolation bye-bye
flow cytometry sorting and
characterization by analytical
ultracentrifugation and dynamic light
scatter by dr. Carly Ross I am dr. Chad
Schwartz senior application scientist at
Beckman Coulter and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Beckman Coulter Beckman
Coulter is a leader in centrifugation
and flow cytometry and has long been an
innovator in particle characterization
lab automation and genomics Beckman
Coulter products are used at the
forefront of important areas of
investigation and discovery for more
information please visit Beckman Coulter
comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the right
clicking on the icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems to the green Q&A button I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. carla ross karlie is a staff
development scientist from Beckman
Coulter life sciences research &
development since 2008 and aided in the
development of the Moe flow Astros and
Astros EQ as well as her current work on
the analytical ultracentrifuge she has
been awarded two patents one flow
cytometer exhorting and the other four
extracellular vesicle work on the AUC in
addition she has been awarded the
corporate excellence and values for her
work ethic and to excellence and
innovation for her
collaborative work on projects for the
astrias dr. ross received her PhD from
Colorado State University from the cell
and molecular biology program with a
focus on mammalian mutation essays on a
flow cytometer she then did a
postdoctoral work in biochemistry by
studying the development of yeast
proteins with a focus on
molecular and protein science dr. Ross's
focus is to burning Beckmann cultures
technology to the cutting edge with
small particle detection of
extracellular vesicles on both the flow
cytometry and ADC platforms before we
get started today I would like to ask a
few poll questions our first question is
what is your current isolation that did
for extracellular vesicles please select
any of the five different answers there
will take a few moments and then I will
report the results
it looks like 36.1% actually do not
study V's they're probably here for the
flow cytometry part 25% use differential
centrifugation 16% use density gradient
centrifugation 19% capture their X's
ohms and extracellular vesicles using
other methods our next question will
populate shortly what size particles do
you analyze using flow cytometry again
multiple answers are allowed here just a
few more moments and we'll get the
answer to this question this survey
most people are studying particles
between 100 and 500 nanometers in size
using the flow cytometry that's pretty
typical 25% of you don't know 20% are
between 500 nanometers to 1 micron and
11.4% would be greater than 1 micron one
final poll question and that will
populate shortly have you considered
using analytical ultracentrifugation or
dynamic light scattering to analyze the
size or purity of your particles it's a
simple yes-or-no question
a few more moments and it looks like 69%
of you say yes that you have considered
using these two different types of
technology to study your particles thank
you everyone for your answers I will now
turn it over to dr. Ross for her
presentation Thank You Chad today I'm
going to be discussing extracellular
vesicle isolation by flow cytometry
sorting and characterization by
analytical ultracentrifugation and
dynamic light scattered I worked in
collaboration with two scientists dr.
Tom Sherman and dr. Alexander schinsky
at Beckman culture Life Sciences
Research & Development in Fort Collins
Colorado I will review three different
topics in this presentation
flow cytometry and extracellular circles
can your system really see V's I will
also discuss folk in a single eb
isolation and then finally focus on
analyzing v's with current and new
techniques just as a quick review what
are Eevee's as seen in this diagram
which is commonly seen and most of our
presentations about extracellular
vesicles there are three main categories
of v's exosomes which is over here on
this side right here microvesicles and
apoptotic bodies so we have exosomes
we have Micro vesicles and we have a
patata bodies now the extracellular
vesicles that were interested in are
secreted membrane vesicles heterogeneous
in size and composition the exosomes
in particular are 50 200 nanometers in
diameter they're released via exocytosis
of multi vesicular bodies they're mostly
characterized through immune cells and
they function as direct contact between
surface molecules of vesicle
and sells so specifically we're
interested in these but what type of
technologies could be used with to
visualize these V's most of the people
that have talked about fixture seller
vesicles look at them either on some
sort of flow cytometer or they look at
them on some sort of nanoparticle device
today I'm going to be focused on flow
cytometry and on the analytical
ultracentrifugation and dynamic light
scatter so our flow cytometry
when you look at it we have to make sure
that it has very sensitive sites
scattered and very sensitive
fluorescence detection on a system this
slide shows are similar for those of us
that run flow cytometry were very
comfortable understanding what eight
peak beads are this is an eight peak
bead with fitzy and PE now there's
usually measured to measure mes f values
but our overwhelming question always is
do you really know how many sourcing
molecules are on your Eevee here's an
example of the fit C and the SF beads
from spirit tech we can see that there
are numbers allocated for each one of
these Peaks this is the mes f or
molecules of equivalent soluble floor
crew we have 2900 and at our detection
threshold only 76
where does your exosome or extracellular
circle fall within that range when you
are running your extracellular vesicles
it's very important that you use these
calibration techniques to be able to
determine your foam resin sensitivity on
your system we can see here on this
histogram that we have the 561 579 log
height versus the number of counts we
have three different populations this
particular population is our human serum
extracellular vesicles we have the we
run eight Peaks with these fluorescently
stain evie simultaneously and this shows
your detection threshold we had the
unstained v's and the
stay newbies and our eight Peaks it may
actually be required for publication of
any extracellular vesicle deep
so therefore this particular information
is important for users to understand
that it needs to be run when running
your samples defining instrument
calibration standards helps determine
flow cytometry small particle
performance there are four different
areas I will discuss today polystyrene
beads my bazooms purchase exosomes and
the electronic pulsar each of these
standards can be used to determine if
the flow cytometer can measure and see
Eevee's running polystyrene beads for
initial determination of optical
sensitivity to eby's is a good start
I've seen in the next video after this
slide the Astra's EQ could detect 200
nanometer beads with 80 nanometer bees
near the noise floor of the system
running 80 and 200 nanometer beads on
the astrious EQ this is an example of
the Astros EQ touchscreen panel as we
start the 80 and 200 nanometer beads you
gently boost and as you do you see the
200 nanometer beads and then you see the
80 nanometer beads within the buffer
noise we have forward scatter on the
x-axis and side scatter on the y-axis
the 80 nanometer beads are above noise
but they're also within the buffer noise
as the sample is stopped the beads are
no longer visible and the instrument
noise is all that remains on the
touchscreen
after watching the video it is difficult
to see the difference between the 80 and
200 nanometer beads however this
histogram shows the side scatter
difference between the 80 and 100
nanometer views as seen on this
histogram the noise floor is visible
well above the 80 and 100 nanometer
beads we have the noise floor here and
we have the 80 and the 100 nanometer
piece there are several benefits to
having polystyrene beads uniform
standardized particles they're easily
accessible and we producible however
there are a few drawbacks side scatter
is dependent on the index refraction
however bees have a much higher index of
refraction than a bees the next
calibration standard is the liposome
lysosomes can be purchased with
different lipid configurations in
different sizes in the next video the
sting di lysosomes are visible on an
instrument touchscreen panel the D hides
ibis ohms as we can hopefully see in the
video had a higher fluorescence value
that di I stained lifeís owns 100
nanometers on the astros EQ the Asturias
EQ is able to see 100 nanometer di I
stained liposomes from noise on both
side scatter and the fluorescence 561
channel the instrument starts with noise
visible then the liposome sample starts
with the forward scatter inside scatter
the like ozone population is a visible
above noise on the sides
her channel using the channel parameter
select Earth image may be changed to the
561 579 fluorescents channel for the dii
fluorescence the stained liposomes are
visible above noise on the fluorescence
and side scatter channels when the
samples the stopped the population on
the fluorescence channel drops to the
noise intensity levels the DAR I like
the sounds had a higher fluorescence
value than noise benefits to using my
bozos as a calibration standard they are
biological the index of refraction is
near Eevee's at 1.45 their reproducible
additional dyes can be either packaged
inside the liposome or attached to the
membrane however there are some
challenges liposomes do not have the
mass or RNA protein content of v's in
all life isms may be a good control for
setting up BB experiments a researcher
could purchase pre verified exosomes
with Western blot a.m. and CD 63
measurements from vendors and use those
to setup their instrument and assay here
I show on mcf7 exosomes purchased from
SBI to help set up the application this
particular histogram shows the noise on
for scattered verses sign scattered here
is our forward scatter channel and our
side scatter channel and what we see is
there is visible noise above the
threshold level but about 10,000 events
per second
the unstained v's you can see here are
located on this particular histogram
again with the four scatter and aside
scatter channels we can see that you
have the exosomes located above the
noise and we also have this population
located up here not quite sure exactly
what that population is the same
population however this particular
sample is stained with di i we have the
dye aggregates we have the exosomes
and then we also either have a
precipitation medium or it could also be
plastic debris from the eppendorf tube
so these sandy B's as seen in this
histogram you can see the exosomes you
can see the dye aggregates and also some
some sort of debris located here
purchased X's ohms are is a good
calibration standard as they have they
are biologically relevant they match the
index refraction mass and density
they're effective for determining
characterization and analysis settings
however the precipitation reagent may
cause interactions or confusion for
example that particular sample there are
a variation in lots and they can be
quite expensive at 50 micrograms per 350
dollars from one of the vendors so we've
discussed three of the calibration
standards the polystyrene beads the
liposomes and the purchased exosomes
the last one we're going to discuss is
the electronic pulsar Sherwood from Wake
Forest University and a PE have
developed an electronic pulsar that
provides discrete trigger and signal
pulses this removes the intrinsic CB
spreading from the B's and measures the
background without lasers and stream
there are two adjustments the coarse
adjustment and the fine adjustment and
two different LEDs for the trigger and
the pulse in the next slide I indicate
how Alex Kachinsky and I set up the
astrias each you
with a pulsar to measure Q and P we
first ran the trigger led into a fiber
couple right here and into and into a
pod more precision optical device this
is where the collection happens on an
sto CQ the adjustable fluorescence pulse
was then placed near the stream here is
the interrogation of the astrias you can
see the LED light located here next to
the stream and it's illuminating but not
touching the street different
fluorescent pulses values were selected
and run independently measured by the
oscilloscope eight peak beats were also
run at the same voltage at the same time
to determine the MAS s values the
electronic pulsar is useful for
instrument calibration for Q and B this
is an example of a histogram taken where
we have the grey population is our eight
peak B's and then we vary the output of
the LED pulsar from one boat which is
our red all the way down to 5 millivolts
this simulates an eighth peak bead
however at the same time you don't have
to purchase beads so it's less expensive
it makes it less complicated to measure
Q and B because you don't have the
intrinsic CV values however there are
some challenges if you want to determine
mas F on your system you have to make
sure and run eight peak beads and it is
not biologically relevant so bringing
these four calibration standards
together we have the liposome z' and
purchased exosomes they are effective
for application development however the
electronic poster and polystyrene beads
are something you can have around the
lab any day and they're definitely
better for instrument standardization
they're very reproducible easy to use
types so we've discussed all the
different parts of the calibration it is
key to remember that running EBS on a
flow cytometer requires clear
understanding
of the instrument capabilities and the
instrument and application standards
that are required to validate the data
we have only discussed the analysis of
EBS on a flow cytometer but can the
instrument be used to isolate evenings
before is discussing flow sign
psychometric isolation at Bea's what are
the current techniques for baby
isolation the gold standard for EB
isolation is the separation of EBS via
serial ultracentrifugation as
specifically noted here is the Beckman
culture Optima EX PN and the 70 Ti rotor
or others you can use I will run through
a typical protocol for human serum
serial extra centrifugation so if we
isolate eby's from human serum this
moment the human serum is isolated in
gel clogging tubes it's fun it's at room
temperature for 20 minutes then it's
spun for 30 minutes at 900 GE on our
Beckman Allegra and the serum is removed
from the tube we have the gel cutting
tube and you place it in a 50 mil tube
equal amounts of PBS are added the tubes
are spun at about 12,000 G for 45
minutes to 2 hours on the Beckman Optima
EX pin and then the supernatant is
removed this is where your EP czars in
the supernatant
and then they spin again at a hundred
thousand G for 70 minutes to four hours
you have a range there but definitely
going over four hours you might be
grabbing too much protein the pellet
that's in those tubes contains the
extracellular vesicles the
ultracentrifugation Eva collection
competes directly with the precipitation
method via similar similar product as
seen on this life this is for example
the total X's own isolation kit and I'll
run through the same procedure that you
do with human serum we go through the
same process of collecting the serum
however the last few steps are slightly
different that you add a 200 microlitre
reagent for one mil which is about 10
dollars per sample according to the
webpage
then you wait for 30 minutes and then
you spin for 10 10 minutes at a thousand
G and the pellet contains EVs and
precipitation medium so these are the
two competing technologies and the
researchers at man Doon and September
2014 went through and analyze the
effectiveness of the ultracentrifugation
bulk methods versus precipitation they
compared the four methods
ultracentrifugation ultracentrifugation
with density gradient and the two
precipitation methods the total X ISM
isolation and XO quick the you see with
opti prep graded provide highest purity
exosomes
noted here and here and the UC provided
the second highest yield located here
although more labor-intensive the UC
methods both provide better provided
better isolation methods
after describing isolation of B B's from
UC or precipitation how does the flow
cytometry compare in the following
section I'm going to describe how the
flow cytometry can isolate single eby's
with additional considerations to keep
in mind users should understand the
noise floor on their system for
scattered and fluorescence parameters
the effects of coincidence or when tui
B's are seen in the laser simultaneously
and make sure to run a test
polystyrene sort and keep in mind
additional controls that might be
required the noise floor might be
affected by numerous particles as seeing
the particles in the sample or sheath
media as seen on this histogram here we
have two different backgrounds we have
one that are caused by filtering and the
other one that's caused by delivery
methods examples and tubes so if you
look here if you see a lot of red it
means we have a lot of background with
the sheath only there's small particles
located in the left-hand side tap water
it's very heavy
and particles there's some with plastic
debris and then we have filtered into a
glass tube the sample media so as you
can see the only one that provides close
or near to street-level is the filter
into a glass tube it's also very
important to pay attention to what type
of delivery method you're using either a
glass syringe a plastic pipette a glass
beaker or even a graduated cylinder when
we are looking at the noise floor the
other thing we have to understand as
we're using a sorter a sorter requires
you to oscillate the stream at different
drop drive frequencies and amplitudes
for the astronauts EQ we definitely
don't suggest changing the frequency but
you may drop change the drop drive
amplitude this is an image that is on
the touchscreen panel of the Astros what
we did is we've looked at the noise
floor and how if you increase or
decrease that amplitude how it changes
the noise floor on your system so for
example we have the red population
located here that is without any drop
drive on this would be if we were just
analyzing our extracellular vesicles
however you can see as you increase the
drop drive you also increase the noise
as the drop drive increases you have an
increase in the population and you may
actually get two populations instead of
one the drop drive is required to
isolate these but understanding how the
components may affect EB isolation is
key coincidence as understanding a noise
floor is integral in testing four V's
being able to see one EB instead of two
is even more essential as a laser spot
for most saitama ters is between five
and twenty five microns the possibility
of multiple two hundred nanometer
particles going through this laser spot
at the same time is high when the sample
is concentrated
I seen in the next video the coincidence
or swarming is caused by Evie's going to
the laser at the same time this is
avoided by properly diluting the same
and measuring the side scatter log
height values some publications may
require a concentration curve
demonstrating that the site scattered
log height values are steady with
decreasing concentration and indicating
an absence of coincidence in this video
clip by artificially created swarming to
show the effect it can have on the
forward scatter and side scatter of the
exosomes by boosting the sample after
stopping the sample the noise population
is visible on the Ford scatter and side
scatter when the lasers are shut off the
population diminishes further so now
that we've seen a video on swarming it's
very important that we control for that
when we're working on our flow cytometry
it is also important to execute a test
sort to determine if the instrument can
sort small particles as seen in this
next histogram there are 81 nanometer
beats and 200 nanometers sorted unfort
scatter insight scatter the result this
sort output was then run for sort purity
the 200 nanometer beats as you can see
are above noise however the noise is
impacting our purity measurements
generally you run purity you hide the
noise and you can't do that so what
we're going to have to do is we're going
to need an additional analysis package
due to the nearness of that population
to the noise these sort outputs were
then analyzed by dynamic light scatter
on the dull Sonic's
the dynamic light scattered data
indicated that the 80 nanometer bee
population sort output from the ash tree
ocq have 80 nanometer bees in it which
feels good and it also didn't have any
200 nanometer weeks now the 200
nanometers we sorted out had 200
nanometers as seen it was measured at
100 95.3 but it also had a few
contaminates located on the lower
left-hand side setting up the experiment
with additional controls helps validate
the easy sorting data
these include sample media with noe
beets
noe bees unstained v's and stained with
noe bees as well as calibration and
fluorescence standards having all of
these different controls helps make sure
that you're looking at Eevee's and not
dye aggregates buffer noise or even
electronic noise
to sum up researchers could use flow
side symmetric sorting for single Eevee
isolation but it's not effective for
bulk isolation there is selected it is
selected for e bees the period is high
but the yield will be low there are
challenges to isolate eby's including
the sort speed dependencies on the drop
dry frequency you know for example if
you run a 70 micron tip at 99 kilohertz
drop drive the maximum speed is about
70,000 events per second and of that you
have a extracellular bussaco and every
other drug now the other issue is that
the droplet volume of the ebee is large
so you may get a hundred and fifty
milliliters of your sample so you might
need a sample concentrator and to do the
purity you may need to use a different
methods such as dynamic light scatter
the isolation methods for extracellular
vesicles to review the isolation of BBS
is valid low yield high specificity be
isolationism
however ultracentrifugation with or
without the density gradient provides
high yield
my purity Easy's is all well and good to
isolate these using this methods but
when I look at a tube I can hardly see
that pellet much less understand what is
inside it and its concentration in the
next section I discuss the methods of
analyzing the EB pellets and sample
using current and new techniques there
are many methods to analyzing EBS after
isolation I am going to include a few of
the mini methods the first method is the
BSA assay which is a very basic method
for measuring protein concentration of
the sample this more of a heuristic
representation of the isolation and
doesn't give you numerical values you
don't know if that's actually blood
serum protein and so it's it's an
effective as a quantitative
understanding of the measurement now
there also is this CD 63 capture beads
purchased them from a beat region and it
confirms that you have v's in your
sample but it is a population that can
be run alternatively users may use
Western blot and take samples to him I'm
not focused on those two I would like to
focus however on the last part of the
presentation on using dynamic light
scatter which is great for measuring
initial size and population and
analytical ultracentrifugation which
gives us this high resolution population
analysis this particular technique has
not been used in many research
publications that we've seen so
measuring the initial size and
population using dynamic light cetera
this is the delsa max Pro and with the
dip cell that comes with it it only
requires 55 microliters of the sample to
be analyzed by dynamic light scatter it
measures the intensity of the light
scattered by the EBS in the sample as a
function of time the system provides the
average size size distribution and poly
dispersity and molecules and the
particles of the solution to note
however that the resolution capabilities
most Els instruments is one two three so
at a 100 and a 300 nanometer particle
may be resolved but populations that are
closer may not I took to fluorescently
labeled samples as you can see here
these are HeLa extracellular vesicles
staying with PK age 26 there are two
different populations we have the high
staying population and we have the low
staying population I took both of those
samples and I place them into the dip
cell for the Delta max I have seen on
the next slide the low population was
much smaller than the high population so
this is what you would get for your dose
of X here's my low sort you see that the
low population has about 137 nanometers
passed the size of the population but on
the other hand the high sort has a
population of 253 mana meters I also
measured the purchased X's own
population our calibration standards
mcf-7 on the Dell cymatics
as seen on this histogram mcf X's own
population has variable size ranges from
122 to 246 and the smaller population is
visible on the lower end the Daedelus
systems work well for populations with
small size ranges but giving a broader
idea of the population of interest of
the sample the researcher needs to know
it's going to be 1 2 3 so you have 100
and 300 nanometers that may overlap but
it will work to give you a quick idea
did I get anything my tubers are nothing
in my tube and what sizes what range of
sizes are we seeing so that's definitely
very helpful to use dynamic light
scattered for those different items now
we can also look at extracellular
vesicles using analytical
ultracentrifugation now this is a
protein chemistry technology and it does
give us high resolution so the
clinical ultra centrifugation is used
for quantitative analysis of
macromolecules in a solution here we
have pictured the Beckman culture
proteome lab Excel AI it's especially
good for protein aggregation antibody
purities determination and mass
researchers can use this for a broad
range of applications to study bio
macromolecules extracellular vesicles
seems like macromolecules to me this is
an image of the inside inside of an AUC
cell where we put the reference and we
put your solvent in here and you
actually measure how this particular
sample compared to its solvent is
sedimenting there are two different
methods for analytical measurement on
the AUC interference and absorbance the
interference module measures the change
in index of refraction between the
solvent and the sample solvent in a two
sector sedimentation velocity experiment
similar to the side scatter that we
think of on a flow cytometer it detects
all particle populations within the
sample as long the concentration is
around 0.5 micrograms per milliliter or
greater it has higher resolution than
the side scatter that we see on the
asterisks EQ and it provides population
measurements as the population sediments
or sedimentation velocity or
equilibrates
at different g-forces and so now we'll
hopefully transfer to another video that
shows you how a BSA sample at 5
milligrams per milliliter is sentiment
at different time points
there there is this is how we look at
the absorbance module now in the
absorbance module you see that it
measures from 190 to 800 nanometers and
then absorbance of the population at a
given radius this is similar to your
hi-tech spectrophotometer
spectrophotometer the xenon flash lamp
will take up to three unique absorbances
per cell per scan so you can look for
example at 2:10 for lipid 260 or 280 for
your DNA or RNA and you can determine
that quite well it's also similar to a
hi-tech spectrophotometer that measures
absorbance of sedimenting populations as
with flow cytometry instrument
calibration we tested the AUC using most
of the calibration standards described
previously the only standard we didn't
employ was the electronic pulsar the
remainder of the calibration standards
were applied to the AUC technology to
determine if the Eevee's could be
measured we first tested the polystyrene
bead sedimentation velocity on
interference module before proceeding I
like to point out the axis labels this
is an open source modeling program for
AUC data called set fit and I am fitting
the data to a sedimentation velocity
value we have the concentration located
on the y-axis and we had the s value or
sedimentation coefficient found on the x
axis the program determines the
concentration of the population with
each sedimentation value dependent on
the slope of the interference data under
the curve so for example here are our
standard B's we ran 22:58
and 104 nanometer beads individually and
together as seen in this graph to
determine if the resolution of the
interference module was great enough to
see the 30 nanometer resolution I see
the sedimentation curve there are three
populations we see 22 and 58 and 104 and
there actually has multiple populations
of each size the goal of this
calibration standard was to determine if
the interference module could measure
the difference in size resolution
however polystyrene mass is much
different for me bees providing a much
different sedimentation coefficient so
the nice thing about the polystyrene
bead sedimentation of course as you can
see these but you can't sediment them
the same way you would sediment Eadie's
we moved on to a more realistic control
manufactured like bazooms from for me
max 100 nanometer lysosomes had a much
lower sedimentation coefficient which at
4.7 versus a hundred for 65% of the
population as you can see here here is
our sedimentation and the data that
resulted from that UCR sedimentation
velocity the percent of the population
the mass and the radius that it measures
the 65% and you can see the histogram
over to the left-hand side it gives us
this pretty clear
decent size however what we found is
that the sedimentation of the liposomes
is faster than heebies but it was much
more similar than then the polystyrene
beads liposomes were also detectable not
only on interference but also absorbance
because of the lipids finally we tested
and developed the AUC analysis by using
the utilized that utilizing the
purchased exosomes mcf7 by running the
samples at different speeds from 3000 to
50,000 rpm the data was then analyzed
and said fit for concentration and
sedimentation velocity to determine the
best resolution or separation of Peaks
the optimum speed was 25,000 rpm with
the interference for the index
refraction resolution and the absorbance
at 210 nanometers 260 to 280 nanometers
for protein and click acid multiple
populate
were visible with the modeled Stokes
radius of 20 to 92 nanometers and we
determined that the purchased exosomes
were effective for application
development as seen on the right hand
side it gives you multiple populations
which correspond to the histograms on
the left hand side in those you have %
populations in mass and the modeled
radius values this is radius not dynamic
diameter so we're running you know
between 60 and 180 nanometers for our
extracellular breasticles from the mcf-7
finally we went through and determined
these particular X's ohms and how well
that they worked now we wanted to move
on to the exosomes we sorted on the flow
cytometry so I analyzed these sorted
kela extracellular vesicles from the
Astros EQ sort on the AUC as we've seen
in this histogram previously I placed
the low and the high sorted fractions
into our AUC spell and centrifuge them
at 20,000 rpm for about I think it was
about 14 hours it could be as low as 5
hours that up to 14 hours we also ran
some controls as we discussed in the
flow cytometry section controls are
incredibly important because these
particles can be confused with all other
types of particles so we run control
such as buffer only no Elise and die
only I ran several different controls to
eliminate nonspecific noise or
aggregates some of the controls you can
see here I didn't put all of them up for
example on the absorbance we looked at
the stain only so peak age 26 only
absorbs at 5:50 well there's a very very
slight response with our control
interference however does see that we
see particles and that might be the
buffer left over or a grits aggregates
that we see on the dyes on the same way
I also looked at unstained Heelys Gila
Evie's at the 550 nanometers we might
get a slight a slight response that
you're not seeing
huge sedimentation curves that you see
on the right hand side with interference
so as outlined on this slide it is the
general protocol for analyzing v's on
the a UCS with Gila extracellular
vesicles in PBS is a solvent as a note
if you use a different solvent let's say
alcohol for example your extracellular
vesicles will sediment way faster than
they would if you were sedimenting on
you know in PBS or even something
thicker like maybe with 5% glycerol we
centrifuge the two sector cell overnight
at 25,000 rpm we measure the
interference at 0.5 micro grams for
velocity experiments and we also looked
at different absorbance they think about
spectrophotometer you can do this as the
thing is spinning round and round and
round it'll measure your absorbance of
your particles on the radius of that
cell we looked at 205 to 210 depending
upon lipid types that the absorbance is
different 260 to 280 for the protein
that nucleic acid then we also were
interested in the absorbance as a two
different dyes for example peak age 67
is 490 and peak age 26 is 550 I analyzed
the data inside fit and overlaid the
concentrations versus velocity for all
the measured measurements and determine
the concentration and groups eby's
populations so here we have a graph and
what if this is is it's the
sedimentation curves overlapped between
the four different types we have the
Gila interference lo sort here
interference we have the peak age 67 we
have the Gila to tether the 210
absorbance and the 550 absorbance and as
you can see from this particular
location we have several different
groupings some which have for example
this one only has lipids so you can
think about that as maybe perhaps
elliptic contamination you have some
that are only dice well that could be
your dye aggregates
so it's telling you the concentration in
your sample
what is
cellular vesicles what is probably
buffered what is die
what is lipid so therefore you can use
those to determine how your
extracellular vesicle prep or method is
working the groups are separated by the
diameter you can see here on this
particular table I have the different
diameters and whether or not they were
located in the interference lipid PK 67
or 26 location concentration could aid
in this method development such as
things that you can think about how
could you use the ABC to help develop
your EB method you could determine well
do we have is is there enough staying in
our TVs we'd have more absorbance are
their lipid contaminants in your sample
how well did the ultra centrifugation
versus the octoprint gradient with
ultracentrifugation clean up your simple
are there more contaminants with
precipitation did I actually sort these
or buffered degree or my flow cytometry
do I have plastic contamination in my
sample do the Ibiza aggregate instrument
and fluorescence standards are required
for effective easy analysis sorting
using the AUC to look at this data and
experimental controls so we looked
through throughout this presentation
we've discussed three main categories
exercise vesicles and flow cytometry how
to isolate Edie's and looking at Eevee
characterization on the flow cytometer
the instrument and fluorescence
standards are required for effective
Indy analysis in Jordan experimental
controls lend validity to your data if
you're going to isolate the
ultracentrifugation with octopus
gradient provides purist EBC isolation
but our flow aside symmetric sorting is
great for selected Eevee isolation on
the astro CQ and finally characterizing
by doing protein quantification and
captured these measures bulk EB quantity
Tulsa max d LS provides initial
population sizing information and quick
analysis and the ABC provides multi
absorbance
interference and it provides high
resolution analysis of the IDI
populations and dye aggregates before I
finish I want to make sure and
acknowledge definitely the Beckman
culture Life Sciences Research &
Development team also we had some
collaborations with dr. Jennifer Jones
at the National Cancer Institute at NIH
and also lab roots for hosting us thanks
for that great presentation Carly before
we get started on the question and
answer session I would like to remind
our audience that you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left of the presentation
window several good questions have
already came in our first question is
could you sort Eevee's based solely on
size and side scatter so they could be
functionally studied letter later
suggesting that the antibodies might
likely alter the functionality of the of
the Eevee's yes so there is some it's
somewhat effective to sort out the e B's
on side scattered however it does find
that sometimes you might get some
contamination with that particular
particle however you know we have
effectively sorted out extracellular
vesicles just on site scattered not with
stain
great thank you for that answer our next
question is in the literature
microparticles extracellular vesicles
exosomes and apoptotic bodies are used
interchangeably to describe these
vesicles
however some papers distinguish
different sizes and sources of these
vesicles using specific names do you
follow any standardized method and
naming as we discussed and I think slide
3 there are as we've seen a huge variety
of extracellular vesicles and I focus on
exosomes which are 50 to 100 nanometers
and they are generally released via a
multi particular body out into the
cytosol another question Jen yes we've
got one more question here the question
is our exosomes solely divined by size
or is there additional requirements to
qualify as annexes oh absolutely
so no they are not to find just by size
you have to make sure that your
extracellular vesicles have been
confirmed by either XM e m or look at
the Western blot for specific antibodies
such as CD 63 CD 9 or CD 81 those will
confirm that you actually have exosomes
and not just junk or debris in your
sample
thank you very much
thank you everyone for attending our
seminar today we'll have to see if chad
has any additional questions thank you
very much the audience for being here
today and listening to our conversation
if you have additional questions please
put those towards Chad Schwartz and we
thank you very much for attending our
seminar today